tu es un robot
si on technologie de l'heure le robot
conversationnel d'intelligence
artificielle qui fascine le monde entier
c'est un système de dialogue
c'est-à-dire la machine a été entraînée
sur à peu près tous les textes qui sont
écrits et il est entraîné à imiter
comment un humain répondrait à des
questions n'importe quel question par
exemple on pourrait demander
pouvez-vous écrire un essai de 1000 mots
sur le statut égal de l'avortement au
Canada
étudiant à la maîtrise en droit à
l'Université migguil Émile participe au
laboratoire building 21 créé par le
professeur Olivier Dion qui s'intéresse
avec des étudiants de tous les profils à
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle dans leur domaine d'études
c'est une réponse qui est assez
intéressante parce que bien que ça ait
peut-être pas en détail niveau juridique
sur
des références à des articles de loi ou
de la jurisprudence spécifique on voit
quand même la structure d'un essai un
essai en droit une dissertation en
sciences politiques le résumé d'une
oeuvre littéraire même si le résultat
n'est pas parfait chat GPT est assez
efficace pour offrir une structure et
des idées au niveau de l'altération moi
je dirais plutôt que ça ça nous offre de
nouveau champs d'exploration mais à
court terme l'arrivée de Tchad JPT écrit
surtout un malaise dans le milieu de
l'éducation bien sûr que ça bouleverse
le milieu de l'éducation est tant mieux
écrire un essai universitaire n'est pas
une fin c'est un moyen
donc l'important c'est de focaliser sur
la fin est-ce qu'on arrive à développer
une pensée critique chez l'étudiant
l'étudiant des moyens vont changer au
cours des années là-dessus Martin
Pitters est d'accord avec lui c'est un
branle-bas de combat les professeurs
vont devoir modifier leur pédagogie leur
évaluation elle fait partie d'un
consortium d'université dans le monde
pour prévenir le plagiat qu'on a des
gens un groupe de travail au sein du
partenariat qui se penche sur la
question on a déjà des formations qui
vont être offertes dans les prochaines
semaines pour outiller nos profs
mais tout va très vite les trucs sur Tik
Tok pour mieux utiliser chat GPT
pullulent déjà une menace pour la
tricherie et le plagiat alors que le
problème s'est amplifié pendant la
pandémie oui une grosse augmentation ça
s'est calmé on revient en salle de
classe et surtout les profs ont appris à
s'adapter et je pense que ça va être
exactement la même chose pour chat
le défi demeure énorme chaque réponse
fournie par le robot est différente et
bien que des logiciels pour détecter son
utilisation soit en cours d'élaboration
ils ne sont pas encore efficaces à 100%
selon des ventils que je peux déterminer
que telle partie du texte à 30 40 60 % a
été généré par une intelligence
artificielle mais ce qu'on peut se fier
à 30 40 50 60 % au collège André boeuf
l'application est bloquée sur le wifi de
l'établissement tant au niveau collégial
que secondaire pour l'instant évidemment
pour l'évaluation ben c'est certain que
cette session j'ai décidé de faire les
travaux en classe ça n'empêche toutefois
pas d'inventer le sujet en classe
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous les
étudiants en tant qu'être humain on est
extrêmement paresseux donc ce genre de
technologie là peut juste nous aider
nous faciliter comme Google Maps je sais
que c'est dans l'extrait mais comme un
moment donné est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
penser par nous-mêmes encourager la
paresse ou plutôt permettre
rajouter des tâches pour en accomplir
d'autres le débat ne fait que commencer
qu'on a découvert Internet et tout il y
avait des personnes qui qui sont
frusquaient ils disaient non il faut pas
l'utiliser c'est dangereux mais
aujourd'hui on est juste obligé
d'utiliser Internet sinon notre société
fonctionne plus à la fin de la journée
c'est quand même mon texte original puis
j'ai utilisé comme une inspiration pour
des idées quand j'en avais pas vraiment
ça fait aussi un peu peur parce que moi
j'étudie en or puis là je me dis genre
ouais l'ordinateur peut créer des des
textes piteux est-ce que mon destin est
assuré les données utilisées par chat
GPT s'arrête à 2021 les nouvelles
récentes ne sont pas incluses ce
reportage n'a donc pas été créé par un
robot pour le moment
[Musique]